كيف ستكون مدن المستقبل هل ستختلف عن مدن
اليوم في عمارتها وتخطيطها المدني في ظل
الظروف المناخيه الحاليه للعالم هذا ما
يطالب به الباحثون فهم يدعون الى التخطيط
لانشاء مبان وتشييد مدن مستدامه قادره على
التكيف مع تغيرات المناخ وظواهر الطقس
المتطرفه تؤدي درجات حراره السطح دورا
مهما في مدى سخونه المنطقه المحيطه وذلك
لان الاسطح الطبيعيه والقابله للاختراق
مثل العشب او التربه تمتص حراره اقل من
تلك الاسطح التي استبدلت بمواد بناء غير
نافذه مثل الاسفلت او الخرسانه والقادره
على امتصاص ما يصل الى 95% من طاقه الشمس
وهذا يفضي الى جزر الحراره الحضريه مصطلح
يستخدمه علماء المناخ للاشاره الى المناطق
داخل المدن التي تشهد درجات حراره اعلى
بشكل ملحوظ مقارنه بالمناطق الريفيه
المجاوره وهو ما يعرض صحه الانسان للخطر
مع التفاقم تاثيرات تغير المناخ وفقا
لوكاله البيئه التابعه للاتحاد الاوروبي
الحل ليس بمستحيل فالطبيعه هي افضل حليف
لنا اذ يعتقد علماء البيئه ان المناطق
المشجره هي الدعامه الاساسيه للتبريد في
المدن ليس من حيث الظل فحسب ولكن ايضا لان
الاشجار تنضح وتولد بخار الماء البارد
هناك ايضا مساله جعل المدن قابله للاختراق
فالارضيات او الاسطح الخرسانيه تمنع دوره
المياه وتعزز الفيضانات لهذا
استبدال جميع انظمه الانابيب الخرسانيه
والخزانات
بانظمه نباتيه مثل حدائق السهول الفيضيه
والبرك والوديان يبدو حلا مثاليا فهل
ستعيد التغيرات المناخيه تفكير الانسان في
كنه المدن برمتها بمعنى ان يتخلى عن تشييد
مدن وفق حاجته الخاصه والضيقه وياخذ بعين
الاعتبار حاجات محيطه وتاقلمه بكل ما فيه
من كائنات